an apex
[Music]
not so fast
[Music]
cover me
tom clancy's rainbow six extraction was
originally called rainbow six quarantine
when it was first announced in 2019 but
for somewhat obvious reasons they
decided to change the name
extraction is an upcoming squad based
tactical shooter due to be released soon
on the 20th of january
the inspiration for the spin-off came
from a limited time event in rainbow six
siege outbreak which introduced the
operation chimera expansion
the outbreak event featured objectives
where teams of three operators fought
off the chimera parasite that landed on
earth
people who came into contact with it
became infected with the organism and
over time would heavily mutate and
become extremely hostile
given the outbreak event there is a
little bit of story we can catch up on
plus run over a few of the important
details that we already know about the
game before it releases later this month
the origins of the chimera parasite are
unknown
but sometime during the soviet era it
was discovered by the russians who put
it on board a capsule and fired it out
into space
early february 2018 the capsule returned
to earth
it crashed near truth or consequences
new mexico
boyd brooks a local of tlc saw a
meteorite fall from the sky one night
and decided to investigate
discovering the capsule at the site he
decided to load it onto his truck and
take it back to a salvage yard where he
would attempt to sell it online
however unbeknownst to him at the time
this would lead to him becoming the
first individual to be infected with the
chimera parasite
and so three days after finding the
capsule brooks found himself making his
way to the sierra county hospital as by
this time he now had a number of red
spikes protruding from all over his body
by this stage the parasite had now
spread to a number of others and medical
personnel were frantically attempting to
treat the infected whose numbers were
quickly increasing and starting to
overwhelm the hospital
one of the doctors ellen mcintosh the
chief of radiation oncology at sierra
county hospital recognised brooks when
he entered the waiting room
but just before she could start helping
in his care his eyes suddenly turned red
over the following seven days macintosh
managed to get a blood sample from
brooks and it began working on a
potential cure for the parasite outbreak
however by now the majority of the
town's population had become infected
and it was also around this time that
those infected by the parasite were
given the name
roaches
up until now government officials have
been successful in preventing the
parasite from leaving the region
unfortunately things were about to take
a turn for the worst
back in the hospital macintosh suddenly
found herself surrounded by the infected
but now they were acting differently
aggressive
fortunately before she was attacked by
one of her infected patients she managed
to barricade herself into the hospital
lab
the police and national guard responded
but with everything they tried the
parasite would evolve and a number of
different types of roaches met them in
the field
some of them fired projectiles
while there were others they had a
hardened shell capable of withstanding
heavy gunfire and explosives
team rainbow was ordered to enter the
town to help prevent the government from
using a nuclear weapon to cleanse the
area
rainbow was able to perform a series of
surgical strikes on nests
these strikes were fast and brutal and
the parasite was unable to respond
they located and destroyed several key
nests
they also became aware of dr mcintosh
and her research and made it a part of
their objective to extract her to help
put an end to the outbreak
although it was considered too dangerous
they were running out of options
and time
rambo was successful in fighting through
the hospital and rescuing dr mcintosh
they then retrieved the capsule from
brook's yard while macintosh continued
working on the cure
several years after the initial outbreak
in new mexico the chimera parasite has
resurfaced and has now spread to various
areas across the united states
fortunately this time team rainbow are a
little more prepared
following the original outbreak a new
division was established
the rainbow exergenus analysis and
containment team
or react for short
for years they've had hundreds of
scientists studying the parasite and the
best way of containing it
however the parasite has also continued
to evolve
it is adapted to earth and now no longer
requires a host
these organisms are called archaeans and
they come in a number of different
variations
team rainbow needs to dive into each of
these new areas to gather more
information about the parasite and find
a way to stop it
rainbow six extraction will feature 18
of the operators in siege including
ta-chanka lion
dock
well i'm not going to read them all out
they're on screen
most of the operators will have the same
abilities they have in siege in fact the
operators were selected based on how
well their abilities would fit into this
new type of gameplay
the easiest way to describe extractions
gameplay is to think of a cross between
left for dead and rainbow six siege
the operators still feel the same but
instead you're shooting parasitic aliens
rather than other operators
similar to the zombies and left for dead
the aliens have a number of different
classes and abilities
currently there is co-op multiplayer and
single-player modes
players will be completing objectives
across three different
maps are split into four distinct
regions new york city san francisco
alaska and truth or consequences
the objectives that are received are
randomly assigned from a list of 13
different tasks
this basically means it'll be very
unlikely to come across the same mission
and location twice
at the end of each objective you can
choose to extract and end the match or
you can continue on to the second round
and then third for greater
rewards however with each round it will
get progressively harder and if your
team wipes you'll lose everything
what creates a more tactical feel to the
game over other shooters is that
supplies are limited health doesn't
regenerate and injuries and deaths will
carry over to each round
so working as a team is a must
rainbow six extraction will be launching
on all the usual platforms xbox
playstation and pc
the game will also have full cross play
cross save and cross progression over
all platforms
also anyone who purchases the game can
invite two friends to play for free for
up to two weeks
admittedly when i first saw the gameplay
when it was first announced i wasn't all
that interested
but the more i've been looking into it
the more potential i can see
i loved my time in siege though i
certainly haven't invested enough time
to be truly competitive at it so this
could be a nice spin-off even if it is a
bit weird to see alien slash zombie type
enemies in a tom clancy game
i certainly don't think this is for the
majority of the hardcore siege fans but
i think this will help bring more people
to the title like those who may have
been put off by this steep learning
curve or as some people put it a
learning brick wall
anyway thanks for watching and i'll
catch in the next one
cheers
[Applause]
[Music]